nous rejoignent et avant de voir en
détail la situation des combats dans les
différentes villes d'ukraine nous sommes
en ligne avec alexis mood ski bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes étudiant à kiev vous avez fui la
capitale et et vous vous trouvez donc
maintenant hacini riffs à 150 kilomètres
au nord de kiev c'est bien cela
oui c'est ça oui ça c'est ma ville
natale donc j'ai résidé si maintenant
vous avez vous avez fut kiev dans
quelles conditions et et quand
j'ai pas filer kif on a eu les
l'éducation à distance donc j'habitais
ici
j'habitais ici avec ma mère et j'ai
décidé de ne pas quitter ma ville
parce que c'est important pour moi de
rester ici de soutenir ma famille quel
est votre quotidien a cerné riffs vous
trouvez ou actuellement les les bombes
tombent sur la ville où c'est calme ah
oui les bombes tombent et il y a deux
jours que 1,3 trois missiles ont été ont
été jetés dans mon quartier est donc
maintenant on n'a pas des verts dans les
fenêtres et à leur situation dans la
ville patrick gras mais on ne peut pas
quitter la ville en raison de déminage
comment se passe comment se déroulent
vos vos journées vous rester en
permanence
enfermez vous pouvez sortir dans la rue
je peux sortir dans la rue pendant les
journées mais je ne peux pas sortir
comme dans la nuit
est-ce que vous manquer d'eau et de
nourriture comment comment se passe
l'approvisionnement en eau et en
nourriture à aceh rni rif
on a de la nourriture les magasins
sont ouverts même dans la première
partie de journée mais je ne peux pas
dire que je ne ris tueur est très
diverse donc
c'est assez simple dans quel état
d'esprit vous vous trouvez en ce moment
est ce que vous avez peur est ce que
vous êtes décidé à rester en cren malgré
tout
je ne peux pas quitter le crime parce
que je suis un homme est alors tous les
hommes ne peuvent pas quitter le
craindre oui on a 18 je veux 55 ans et
ça exactement à est
aussi un jeu peut pas quitter ma ville
parce que comme j'ai déjà dit les routes
à la ville sont minées donc on reste ici
et on se bat on va arrêter l'invasion
vous avez décidé de prendre les armes
vous personnellement ou pour l'instant
vous vous restez
là où vous vous trouvez où vous habitez
pour l'instant je reste ici avec ma
famille parce que je suis un peu malade
mais peut-être dans le futur proche
j'avais pu rejoindre la défense
territoriale
quel est l'état d'esprit des gens autour
de vous est ce que les gens ont peur est
ce qu'ils sont décidés à à se battre et
à résister est ce que la panique vous
envahit ou pour l'instant vous vous
restez plutôt calme
il n'y a pas d'aidés grande panique
plutôt les gens à sont sont prêts sont
prêts à
aller
à condition que ces conditions
donne-nous demeure donc
bien sûr que tous les gens sains croire
à la victoire mais de crin avec le
soutien des d'ouest parce que sans le
soutien de l'ouest ça serait trop
difficile pour nous l'union européenne a
promis de d'envoyer des armes mais elle
a aussi dit qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'intervention armée puisque la
l'ukraine ne fait pas partie de l'otan
comment réagissez-vous à cela en ukraine
alors un ukrainien sûr que l'on
désire
que l'europe on voit les armes qui est
europe 1 on va les soldats mais j'ai
bien sûr comprendre que que l'invasion
de l'otan peut vraiment déclencher la
troisième guerre mondiale donc c'est
assez
expects abl vous êtes vous êtes très
connectés ou pas est ce que vous arrivez
à suivre les informations et si oui
comment via les réseaux sociaux
peut-être
voyez nous les réseaux sociaux le
messenger télégramme qui est très
populaire en écran donc c'est peut-être
le moyen de prendre du ici et vous
suivez les combats les discours de votre
président le volodymyr zelensky par
exemple oui monsieur yvan toutes les
discours tous les combats tous les
atouts les nouvelles merci beaucoup
d'avoir témoigné sur france 24 merci à
vous à l'excellent mood ce qui vous êtes
étudiant donc et vous trouvez à czerny
rifains une villa à 150 kilomètres au
nord de kiev merci à vous et et bon
courage cherchez bien sûr